all right Cuba the Sun keep you a
difference number three and if I bees
want to go to it quite quickly I'm not
even going to approve I'm just going to
state them for you
partly because these two I'm about to
show you are on the reference ship
okay so instead of accusing us some I'm
gonna do the son of cubes okay think
about what the word mean this means
you've got two cubes and you're adding
them together so here is the sum of
cubes now some of you should come
extraordinary memory should remember
this from you town does anyone remember
any takers I'm gonna write that let's
pause for a second I have got written
here this one okay now I use this to
help me because the next term is not to
a bit the way I remember it is the to a
big comes from here that's quite a
different thing they're stopping very
slightly different that comes next
anyone yet it's a minus and then it's
not so maybe it's just just one a bit
okay just one of them and then you've
got the V squared or the end that is the
sum of cubes like I said you have this
on your reference sheet and right below
it you have the difference of cubes
just like before instead of adding
you're going to subtract and I'm going
to show you what the characterization is
and then I'm going to ask that same
question I asked before what do you know
what he knows
so you remember how we went from cube of
a son to cube of a difference remember
that and all the terms were pretty much
identical but what change was the
operations yeah have a look at these two
do you notice all the tape two terms are
the same but what's change is the
operations okay and then have a look at
those operations what do you notice
about the operations see these two these
two have swapped these two also squat
what about that last one it's close same
okay now I've just found pointed out
this is the third time I'm pointing out
now can you get them trying to remember
get you to remember this these are on
the reference sheet
however some unlucky people be in the
past didn't get a reference sheet so we
had to remember this whole thing off by
heart the hardest part of this with the
science getting them in the right order
so we learned in premium to help us
remember the order on the science we've
seen this before yeah okay a few of you
alright so for most of you who have it
so stands for locked onto us
same opposite always now I wonder as you
look at the two results if you can see
the same opposite always positive sum of
cubes the first sign is the same the
first operation I should say the second
one is going to be opposite this last
guy he doesn't care he's always going to
be a plus okay now the reason why I'm
pointing that out now even though you do
have a reference sheet is because if you
have to search for this result on the
reference sheet what does it cost you
time okay and with a bit of familiarity
you'll get to this it's okay it's not as
bad as it looks even
feel intimidating right now that's
because there's lots of other stuff on
the board to remember is about okay
[Music]